tchernobyl vingt ans après nous
poursuivons notre série consacrée à
l'explosion nucléaire avec aujourd'hui
l'une des traces des plus frappantes de
la catastrophe
la ville fantôme de pripiat trois jours
après l'accident cette commune la plus
proche du réacteur avait été évacué
depuis elle est interdite d'accès et
exceptionnellement patrick esther et
eric jeanne et ont pu se rendre sur le
site et tout particulièrement à l'école
du village
à cinq kilomètres seulement du réacteur
numéro 4 de tchernobyl qui a explosé le
26 avril 1986 pripyat
seuls quelques hommes reviennent de
temps en temps dans la ville fantôme
martyrs de l'atome il y a vingt ans
c'était la cité du bonheur le symbole du
communisme triomphant et de la vie
radieux et la centrale nucléaire devait
à terme posséder dix réacteurs 4
fonctionnait déjà aujourd'hui la forêt
envahi les rues les arbres défonce le
bitume
aujourd'hui youri tatar tchouk nous sert
de guide
nous avions rendez vous avec rim à l'une
de ses collègues elle est morte il ya
deux semaines cancer 80000 personnes
vivaient ici tout participé à l'
aventure de ce qui devait être la plus
puissante centrale atomique du monde
trois jours après la catastrophe la
ville contaminée par les poussières
radioactives a été totalement évacué
pour que les habitants acceptent de
partir
les autorités leur avaient promis que
c'était pour quelques jours seulement
ils ne sont jamais revenus
il avait laissé tous leurs meubles leurs
animaux domestiques et les
réfrigérateurs plein de nourriture puis
l'électricité a été coupée
les animaux sont morts et dans la ville
une odeur pestilentielle
les mises à plein youri veut absolument
nous montrer l'école secondaire de
pripiat amusé que personne ne visitera
jamais 540 élèves de 7 à 17 ans apprenez
sur ses bancs dans la précipitation
leurs petites affaires sont restées le
calendrier 86 n'indiquera jamais rien à
la date du 26 avril
comme si le temps s'était figé disques
33 tours ancêtres des services et au
milieu des livres de la bibliothèque le
boulier pour apprendre à compter la
caisse enregistreuse du réfectoire et
dans la cuisine un masque à gaz
oubliez les professeurs enseigner
l'histoire glorieuse de l'urss des
plaines de l'ukraine grenier à blé
aujourd'hui contaminés et incultivables
pour des milliers d'années et bien sûr
lénine sur les panneaux d'affichage des
trempés par l'eau radioactive qui
s'infiltre et dégoulinant raison de la
fonte des neiges
prémonitoire ces images devaient
apprendre aux enfants les gestes à
effectuer en cas d' alerte nucléaire